sylvain dietrich nous reçoit dans la
maison de famille à belfort là où
stéphane et lui ont grandi il est
descendu de paris pour assister au
procès qui débute demain devant la cour
d'assises de vesoul
depuis 24 ans il se bat épaulés par des
anonymes et des personnalités pour
connaître le nom de l'assassin de son
frère mon frère c'était une personne qui
avait si vous voulez beaucoup de respect
pour les autres c'était ça toujours été
une belle personne et c'est pour ça
qu'on quand on pense à lui en famille on
ne pense qu'à deux belles choses
c'était quelqu'un qui était plutôt
solaire c'est ça que je veux dire dans
le box des accusés
christophe blain le meilleur ami à
l'époque de stéphane devenu conseiller
immobilier dans le var il est le dernier
à avoir vu la victime vivante
lors de son audition par les enquêteurs
en 2015 il avoue être l'auteur des faits
malgré des aveux les dietrich sont
persuadé qu'ils ne connaîtront jamais
les circonstances exactes du drame
qu'est ce que vous attendez ce procès je
souhaiterais profondément qu'il ait une
peine exemplaire
déjà pour l'acte et que justice soit
rendue à stéphane mais aussi pour que
d'autres personnes
quand on commet un acte comme ça aussi
fort pour que d'autres personnes ne
puissent parole me rencontrer je pense
que c'est quelqu'un de dangereux très
dangereux en rup le à l'issue du procès
sylvain dietrich continuera son deuxième
combat celui de faire annuler le délai
de prescription pour les crimes de sang
actuellement fixé à 20 ans